er ist jung er hat studiert aber er
verkauft sich für billiges geld eine
kampagne gegen lohndumping
die idee stammt von diesen beiden
geschäftspartner
es war dass logan gegen kreativ
prostitution
also wir wollen einfach verhindern dass
die leute sich unter wert verkaufen
arbeiten zu niedriglöhnen in der
kreativbranche damit haben sie auch
schon erfahrung gemacht
deshalb gründeten sie ihre
vermittlungsagentur für kreative es gibt
auf der einen seite die entwicklung dass
leute immer mehr ausgebeutet werden es
gibt plattformen wo man dann 100 leute
irgendwie ein logo design und nur der
gewinner erhält dann geld dafür
das sehen wir einfach als absolute
ausbeutung die berliner kreativ branche
trifft sich in solchen hippel workspaces
webdesigner texter fotografen
doch manche von ihnen müssen mit
honoraren auf sozialhilfeniveau
auskommen
knapp 1000 euro im monat in ihrem
firmenvideo zeigen die jobvermittler wie
sie arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer
zusammen bringen sie vermitteln die
kreativen zu einem festen tagessatz
viele sagen ja immer 300 euro als tages
hat das klingt zu viel
das ist ganz normal für leute die mit
finanzen nichts zu tun haben
aber wenn man das mal hoch und runter
rechnet kommt man halt schnell darauf
dass man da keine rente von zahlen kann
dass man da nichts davon zurück
zurücklegen kann
esther schar hüls ist grafikdesigner
sein
sie wurde von den beiden an eine
werbeagentur vermittelt dafür erhalten
sie zehn prozent provision von ihrem
honorar eine woche später die nächste
und mittlerweile gibt es auch agenturen
die dann auch wieder kommen
berlin ein eldorado für die
internationale kreativ szene doch für
jeden dritten reicht das geld kaum zum
leben statt alleine zu hause zu sitzen
arbeitet es dass hüls lieber zusammen
mit anderen selbständigen hier findet
sie anregungen kontakte und manchmal
auch neue jobs
ihr tagessatz erscheint hoch auf den
ersten blick also theoretisch fängt bei
450 an 450 500 euro
wie oft ist es kommt sehr darauf an im
sommer ist es ganz oft so dass man öfter
mal gebucht wird aber dann heißt es
jetzt auch nicht jeden tag sondern das
ist dann vielleicht ein zweimal im monat
dann ist aber auch wieder zwei monate
nicht
weltweit wächst der markt für die
kreative wohin sie sind jung wollen
unabhängig sein
doch über die schattenseiten sprechen
sie ungern nach jedem auftrag wartet die
ungewissheit sie sind gewerkschaftlich
nicht organisierten fehlen
tarifabschlüsse ihre schöne heile welt
belächeln manche mit zynismus tagessatz
hast du gerade tages sagt ehrlich gesagt
in der kategorie denke ich gar nicht
du kriegst genug geld damit machen hast
und das ist es dann auch irgendwie
zwischen 8 und 16 stunden machen auch 20
manchmal auf 24 das aber sei aber in
tagessätzen kannst du die welt männer
aber die grafik designerin hat für sich
dazu gelernt auf lohndumping lässt sie
sich heute nicht mehr ein
da muss man dann auch um seine eigene
energie und auch um seinen eigenen
dass man auch seine unkosten hatten das
zu schützen muss man einfach auch
hingehen und und grenzen setzen
in ganz deutschland arbeiten 15
millionen menschen in der kreativbranche
aber anderes als esther schaffen ist die
meisten nicht den wert ihrer arbeit auch
durchzusetzen